DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello, my
name is Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager at Google.
And I'm here with
Weston Hutchins,
who's also a product
manager working on GKE.
Everyone loves a
good origin story.
Wes, you've been with GKE
On-Prem since the beginning.
What is the origin
story of GKE On-Prem?
WESTON HUTCHINS: So, thanks
for having me here, Dustin.
You know, GKE On-Prem
really started
by talking to GKE customers.
So these were people
that had decided
they were using Kubernetes.
And they were loving the
manage experience we give them
in the cloud, but
they needed a solution
that runs in their
own data center,
for a variety of reasons,
mainly regulatory.
Some of them had workloads
that they couldn't really
bring up to the cloud
quite yet, legacy things.
And they were looking
for a solution
that worked in both places.
They had been using primarily
do-it-yourself Kubernetes,
which is pretty easy
to get up and running.
But the real challenge comes
on the day-two operations.
So things like
securing your cluster,
doing it in high
availability mode,
just being able to scale
up the cluster up and down,
these are all things that
GKE does really well.
And we talked to a lot of them.
And I went and talked
to a couple of devs
inside and said, hey,
is it possible to take
the GKE management stack, all
the cluster management that we
do and a lot of
the node features,
wrap that up into a package
and bring it into a customer's
On-Prem environment?
And at first, people were
like, oh, I don't know.
But over time, we
started to pull together
prototypes and pieces.
And we built a package
that we could give off
to customers that was
then connected back
to our hosted control plane
that offers a local Kubernetes
cluster running
in a data center.
And you know, when we talked
a lot about Anthos at Next
this year, Kubernetes
and GKE On-Prem
really formed the
base of that package.
And we then start to layer
other types of services
and, I will say, ease of
use features for developers,
like Istio and
Knative, that can run
in this portable environment
where you can run it
in other clouds, and you can
run it in an On-Prem place.
So that's really how
GKE On-Prem came about.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And GKE
On-Prem is ultimately
the heart of Anthos.
WESTON HUTCHINS: It is.
The Kubernetes is
the base underpinning
of all of the stuff we build on.
It gives us that
portable environment,
that infrastructure
abstraction, that
allows you to run the same
workloads in different places
without having to
change anything.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It all
starts with the GKE On-Prem.
And then the Anthos pieces
plug in around that.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Correct.
Yeah, the base
layer is Kubernetes.
It is the portable
infrastructure abstraction
that allows us to run in
an on-prem environment
and in the cloud.
And then the other ones
build on top of that.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: But
Kubernetes by itself
just isn't enough, right?
So what are the other key
pieces that plug in that
make it enough?
WESTON HUTCHINS:
Yeah, Kubernetes
is extremely powerful.
But for a lot of customers I
talk to, especially developers,
they don't really want all
the bells, and whistles,
and knobs of Kubernetes.
And this is really where
Knative and Cloud Run fit in.
They say, you can take the
normal app development workflow
that you're used to-- so push
to deploy, build in the cloud,
build an app, have
different versions,
scale those out-- and under
the covers, that will actually
go and configure
traffic splitting
services in Kubernetes,
ad load balancers,
scale up apps, scale down apps.
That's really what
Kubernetes is supposed to be.
It's the base layer
that gets it done,
but we want to
make things easier
for developers and operators.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And is this meeting,
those same customers
that you talked to
at the beginning
that didn't want
those day-2, day-92
operations, don't
want to worry about those
operations and that management,
are we hitting the mark here?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
You know, for the most part,
most customers don't really
want to be in the business
of operating and managing
their own cluster.
They would rather
let someone that
knows how to do this at scale
with many, many customers
take that over for them, so they
can just focus on writing apps.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
And what are you
hearing in terms
of hybrid workloads and the
challenges and solutions
to hybrid computing?
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
So the biggest challenge that we
ran into is just a lot of these
customers either have data that
cannot leave the data center
for regulatory reasons, or
maybe they need to run workloads
at the edge, so super fast,
low latency processing.
They have standardized
on Kubernetes.
They said, that is
the app platform
that we want to use in the
cloud and in these environments,
but we really need
a full managed stack
running in these places.
And so GKE On-Prem does
give them that ability
to keep data local, to
work within their existing
regulatory environments, but
also offers them a path forward
to cloud.
This is the real big,
key benefit of Anthos
is that you can start to
use cloud workflows, right?
You can start to
think about writing
apps that are
resilient to clusters,
nodes that can go down.
You can start thinking
about global apps
and how to do traffic
splitting across them.
But you can use that in your own
environment when you're ready.
You can move up to the
cloud at your own pace.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: It's
a real hybrid world.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Yeah.
For a lot of
customers, it really
is about training and
the people that you
hire, training them
on the right tools,
so that they don't have to
learn different types of tooling
for these different
environments.
That's a lot of the magic
of what Anthos brings.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Wes,
thank you very much.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Absolutely.
Thank you.
[SOFT MUSIC]